okay so after our ms marvel episode 3
breakdown broke the internet and trended
worldwide last wednesday because
everyone watched it i've been very
excited to check out episode 4. it's
filled with easter eggs hidden details
and a lot of things you missed you seem
to be missing a lot recently don't you
including our episode 3 breakdown but
i'm going to do you a solid one and
include some of the easter eggs and
discussions on the characters in the
last century so you don't have to go
back and watch it as a thank you for
doing this amazing favor i expect that
thumbs up button hit and also make sure
you sit around until the end of the
video where i may
may explain why we didn't get a chance
to cover last week if you're interested
i don't know it's not that big of a deal
anyway without the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into miss
marvel now last episode i explained
najma's ties to the bangle along with
some clues about where it comes from we
opened in british occupied india during
1942 which is five years before india
gained independence from the uk this was
of course also during the second world
war and we joined the jinn as they
searched for the bengals described as
supernatural beings from another
dimension jinn are very much genies
though they have been described as both
good and evil spirits in the episode
they were referred to as the unseen and
also the clandestine which are two
groups that come from the comics the
unseen are a group of aliens that work
with nick fury potentially tying in with
the end of far from home and possibly
also setting up the character's
appearance in the upcoming marvels movie
clandestine were actually x-men villains
created in the 90s and they were the
progeny of adam of destin as well as
ellalith who just so happened to also be
a gin adam was born in the 1100s
ravencroft's england and he was badly
wounded one day however he had a full
recovery after dreaming of an inhuman
woman and this led his local villagers
to name him adam of destin adam became
impervious to harm and during the
crusades he wasn't able to be injured
early on during them he fought a wizard
with a magical gem and upon killing him
this was broken open which is when
elinoluth came forward as a genie she
made him immortal and the two then fell
in love the pair had children and they
lived in ravens crofts for centuries
building a family and also their team
now i probably won't spend too much
longer talking about them as the show
features completely different versions
of the lineup with their own origin
story but some of the comics they are
also immortal the desperate to get home
and view the bangles as being as a way
to return to their own dimension they
need them to unlock the newer which is a
word that actually translates to light
this is something that we've seen
throughout the series and it could end
up giving cameron his powers in the
comics he was an inhuman that was made
up of light and kamala of course also
uses the bangles to control this now it
turns out that the clandestine need a
power source to send them home and they
ended up turning on kamala the entry
closed out with them becoming wedding
crashers at her brother amir's big day
what an
idiot
oh what a loser
now episode 4 is titled seeing red and
it features the introduction of a miss
marvel character from the comics this is
the red dagger who we'll talk more about
in just a bit now speaking of seeing red
we get the marvel studios logo and in
the background can hear the song summer
nights by rajinder and wise child really
chilled way to start off the episode and
we joined kamala and her mother heading
out to pakistan over the pa we can hear
the pilot speaking urdu and there's a
lot of cultural references laced
throughout the episode we also see
kamala wearing her green pilot jacket
that was based on carol danvers flight
suit nice little touch here as it also
has captain marvel's logo on it too
kamala is tightly holding onto a napping
pillow which is a sloth and as we know
from the first episode her youtube
channel is titled sloth baby productions
she's been doing what we all did on
flights as kids drinking canada dry
which i used to sip on my way to spain
before i started hitting the hard stuff
of a shot of absinthe to the eye and we
see her texting nakia
don't know how you get signal love
bus suppose they do wi-fi on planes
these days but when i was a kid you were
lucky to get tv you had to walk seven
thousand miles just to get a marvel
comic you did and when you got there it
was just squirrel girl and squirrel girl
anyway lost it a bit there and this text
message is a far cry from the neon signs
and animations that we got in the first
episode in that entry kamala was
constantly going off into fantasies
which was shown in the graphics that the
series used however here it's toned down
massively suggesting she's had to come
to grips with the real world and no
longer carries the childlike wonder that
she once had in karachi she comes across
not only her cousin zainab and always
but also her grandma she instantly goes
off on her daughter being like oh you're
on a diet or some
which i know my wife has to put up with
from her mother my sister does two from
our mother so this is like a big easter
egg about my life anyway karachi is
called the city of light and this
location of course plays upon the powers
to manipulate hard light that the bengal
has karachi is a very important location
as it was also shown on the front of the
train in the vision last week the title
screen has now also changed up massively
to fit with the location and this now
includes urdu text and graphics of
temples at her grandmother's she comes
across a room with several newspaper
clippings detailing historic events in
the country the first one showcases
several people at a train station which
i believe comes from the partition
journeys that were talked about earlier
in the season you also have the birth of
pakistan clipping which discusses lord
mountbatten mount ban was the viceroy of
india and he oversaw the partition
several decades later he was
assassinated by the ira in 1979 his also
mentions of tributes to kuwaiti azam
which means great leader the surname
jenna refers to muhammad ali jinnah who
was the first governor general this is
very much her grandmother's way of
remembering as so much was lost during
the partition she also has a picture of
aisha and kamala hears about the fact
that she's a gin now we've slowly
started to learn a bit about the bangle
and last week we saw how clandestine
came across it they found it attached to
a blue arm which i think further backs
up the theory that this is actually of
cree origin in our episode 1 breakdown
we discussed how we thought that it was
the mcu version of the [ __ ] bands and
i think this arm backs up that idea we
watched his kamala travel through what
could be the negative zone when she put
it on and the bands are also of cree
origin they were gifted to captain
marvel by the supreme intelligence but
they came with a curse as they trapped
one inside the negative zone in the
comics marvel got stuck there and on
earth after rick jones found the other
one he used it to switch places back and
forth with marvel in the opening of
episode 3 we also got this line about
their usage when they talked about how
they'd need two in order to travel home
you heard what that man from the temple
said
he said we would need two
so i think there will be another one
that pops up in the series and
potentially it might allow them to
return home by having them swap places
with someone in their own dimension and
there's also the carvings of the ten
rings on the floor potentially making
this one of wenwu's temples the ten
rings themselves also came from an alien
world namely the mcluhan's home planet
the bangle could end up being made from
the same technology as the rings are and
there was even a hint of them in the
first episode so i kind of have a theory
that it's all connected
and that we learn more about this
connection in the marvels if the bengals
are of cree origin then that ties them
to the first captain marvel movie as
carol of course worked alongside them so
in the marvel she could end up
investigating them and with kamala being
tied to the bengals as well we'll kind
of bring it all together to make it's
all connected
as i've been saying you might even get a
cameo by brie larson at the end of the
series and who knows the power source
used to charge up the bangle and send
clandestine home might even end up being
souped up by her i do think that they
will in fact get home and that the
ending will be somewhat of a happy one
for them even if they're the bad guys
for now because it would be weird if ms
marvel just killed them all and they
didn't go home
can't really see that being the case but
yeah they might go all out with it i
mean it is disney that they love
murdering people now from here she hears
the story of the stars once more and
confirms that it is the same train from
the visions in episode 2 we also got a
flash of najma reaching out to kamala
which could have been seen through
aisha's eyes perhaps this was her
potentially betraying her and the train
rushing towards her might have caused to
death or something not too sure as this
storyline isn't really in the comics per
se though it does take inspiration from
them so i'm not dropping a theory time
you don't deserve it your god damn chump
see you chump now the episode itself is
heavily based on issue 12 of ms marvel
and it actually opens with her in the
airport before she travels to her
grandmother's lots of similar setup
devices with her going through the
airport and she also learns a lot about
her history at her grandma's home if you
want to read the comic book for free you
can without breaking any laws as you can
actually get it by scanning the qr code
at 14 minutes and 32 seconds which is on
the photographer's stand now after a
dream in which she sees several visions
kamala and co go to the boat club for
lunch however they aren't allowed inside
because of their policy on jeans and
outside they meet kamala's auntie they
tour the streets of old town and it's a
really great scene that kind of gives
you a quick run-through of the culture's
dress and style i also like that the
creative team didn't add the yellow
filter that you tend to get when
characters go to anywhere that isn't
america or europe this makes the entire
environment actually feel authentic and
i love exploring it as much as kamala
does we can also see that kamala is
wearing a new jersey avengers con
t-shirt which was of course a big thing
in the first episode she saved zoe and
got the t-shirt and hey i might bloody
buy one two now her curtain refers to
her as an abc which means american-born
confused desi major reach here but by
the restaurant we also see abc so put
that in your breakdown ryanairy a bloody
dare you shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy after
getting very useful directions to
karachi station kamala heads there to
see if she can piece together anything
she ends up going into the restricted
zone and she done her ms marvel mask as
she moves through the area we can catch
an ant-man mural and this showcases the
character growing from small to big like
you when you have a night with ryan
aries mom gotcha again you punk shut the
[ __ ] up ryanairy now this was created by
artist adrian alfona whose name also
pops up on the mural alongside sarah
hussein who's worked on several marvel
movies such as the eternals there's also
been a number of nods to ant-man in the
series and i think it would be great if
we got a voice cameo by paul rudd tying
into scotland's podcast here she's
ambushed by red dagger which leads to
the second train station fighting the
mcu since avengers infinity war red
dagger is played by aramis knight who
you might also recognize as being from
into the badlands there's also a little
line about ms marvel potentially being
canadian and this is a nice little line
as a man velani is actually canadian and
the red dagger is someone that was first
leaked on the back of funko pop boxes
for the show this is a character that
doesn't make all that many appearances
in the comics but over the last couple
of years he slowly started to drop into
some titles kareem aka the red dagger
first appeared in ms marvel vol 4 issue
12. this was post civil war 2 and he
popped it when kamala went to pakistan
to discover her heritage this is similar
to the show where she's been back into
karachi to learn more about the vision
of the train najma and also the bengal
in the source material kamala met kareem
at her grandmother's home and he said he
was studying for his university entrance
exam after an awkward first meeting they
started to hit it off and became best
buds now the pair met again in their
vigilante personas when kamala stopped
an illegal subzol well operation and
here she came across the red dagger in
his disguise he scolded ms marvel for
wading in and blowing up a truck because
she was pretty careless and didn't
understand the complex local situations
she also didn't check in with the other
local heroes before doing this and it
was pretty much a valuable lesson for
kamala now something similar ends up
happening in this episode during the
chase scene which kind of turns into a
disaster because kamala isn't prepared
now dagger later appeared in issue 23 as
a foreign exchange student needing a
language credit for his university
entrance requirements and he helped her
stop a runaway train kareem then buddied
up with a bunch of knock-offs of ms
marvel when kamala seemingly disappeared
wonder if they had hockey pets in
reality kamala was over at lee private
school very on the nose after taking a
break from the super life kareem also
kissed kamala in the aftermath of a
battle with the knockoff inventor
gregory knox just as bruno had returned
from wakanda awkward now he went back to
karachi realizing that new jersey was
kamala's domain and that he needed to go
and protect his home whilst she looked
after hers now kamala and dagger kind of
fight to his stalemate and she makes fun
of him for learning to jump like that
from the ninja turtles he's wearing
green as well as cloth over his face
similar to them teenage mutant hero
turtles daggery buffs this by saying
donkey kong which was of course a
platform game dagger then says
come with me if you want to live what
which is of course a play on this line
from terminator 2.
come with me if you want to live
kamala is then taken to the red daggers
and we see that the group are highly
integrated into the area even with their
own hideout hidden in a restaurant this
shows that the locals are very accepting
of heroes and that they'll do what they
can to help and hide them inside she
meets waleed and they discuss the red
scarf and its meaning this red scarf is
something kamala adopts in the comics
for her costume and we know from the
trailer and so on that this will appear
as part of her outfit in the show too
waleed is played by farhan akhtar a big
bollywood actor who's a nice addition to
the show now they very much discuss the
difference between the legend of the gin
and the reality of it thor is brought up
as being someone who would be considered
a jinn if he crashed in the right area
and therefore they could very much be
viewed as being gods willie discusses
how the clandestine are from another
world and they also go over different
dimensions the newer is the only thing
dividing the world and though i
mentioned before that it could be the
negative zone it could also be more
straightforward than that the painting
from earlier in the episode actually
looks like people leaving manure and we
discover that if it's destroyed the
clandestine's world will ravage 616.
walid also points out the inscription on
the bangle
we'll talk about what this means towards
the end of the video but it could be a
hint towards aisha looking for her and
yeah let me know your thoughts below on
what it means from here we go to damage
control supermax prison which looks
pretty much exactly like how it did in
the she-hulk trailer the clandestine are
being taken in and they managed to
escape and fight the damage control
forces who fire sonic weapons at them
these were also seen in the shirak
teaser and my guess is that they fire
concussive blasts cameron is ditched by
them due to his choice last week and
juxtaposing this family split up we see
kamala's grandmother is fine with her
trying to figure out who she is she
talks about the identity struggle that
she's gone through due to england
messing up everything and there is some
acceptance that kamala finds in this
kamala's grandmother talks about
struggling with her identity and on top
of this kamala now has to deal with the
fact that there's this gin side of her
that's being thrown into the mix this
idea of her starting to become happier
is also reflected in the text which ends
up being displayed to us in the form of
kites she finds kareem and just gets to
hang out with him and his friends really
nice scene of her just chilling and i
love that this series takes the time to
just relax and build a character i think
it's one of the most well thought out
disney shows and after i was kind of met
on the first episode due to it just kind
of going through the motions of being an
origin story it's really really grown on
me at its heart it's about identity
family and also it's just a solid
coming-of-age story you also get a great
mother and daughter scene that follows
it and i think this probably has the
most fleshed out side characters in any
disney plus show miniba discusses why
she fled to america and that she just
couldn't take the stories about aisha
due to how they made her look to others
minibar of course didn't want kamala to
do anything with the bangle early on and
you can finally see things from her
point of view there's also talk about
how there's lots of toffee boxes in the
room and this was also on the box that
the bangle was sent in with help from
the daggers kamala ends up training her
powers further and she's also given a
blue waistcoat which will of course
later be adapted into her costume at
this point they're attacked by the
clandestine which leads to a lead taking
them on by himself we get an awesome tuk
tuk chase scene through the streets and
this reminded me a lot of the one from
octopussy due to their bond james bond
kareem waleed and kamala end up working
together to some extent but it is a bit
of a mess in the streets really well put
together chase scene though with
motorbikes doing endos people getting
hit by trucks and the whole area is
bustling with life adding to the
dynamism of it waleed ends up leaving
himself up into attack in order to save
kareem and kamala and najma kills him
showing how ruthless she is this eye for
an eye mentality leads to dagger taking
out a clandestine member and najma stabs
the bangle which ends up transporting
kamala back in time to the partition she
sees the train head on like how it was
in the vision making me think that she
might have actually swapped places with
aisha as we discussed earlier this
bangle in the comics switched out
captain marvel and rick jones so it
could end up doing the exact same thing
here now it's actually theory time their
time everytime
so i actually think that kamala might
end up being the one who leads her
grandmother using the stars to guide her
and this is why the person who did this
was never seen though it was thought to
be aisha with kamala being in the past
this would make a lot of sense it also
wouldn't require the tva to step in as
it wouldn't create a branch timeline if
this was always supposed to happen
kamala has of course heard this story
thousands of times as well so she'd know
to stay hidden in order to not destroy
the time space continuum therefore she
will likely keep out of sight save her
grandmother and then potentially find
eyeshare to discover what's going on
again this also ties back to the
inscription
it says what you seek is seeking you
[Music]
this could mean that the bangle pulled
her here to find aisha and this is what
the trip throughout the past will be
it's also possible that she's gonna go
to the red daggers and this will be how
they end up learning so much about the
bracelet that they can then pass on to a
lead no idea how long the organization
has been about but they could exist in
the past and it could all tie together
for some nice timey winey wibbly wobbly
stuff great episode and i really enjoyed
it bit of a mind at the end but yeah
nice way to close it all out
[Applause]
now as for why i didn't cover last week
it basically just boils down to a number
of reasons that made it pretty difficult
for me to fit it into my schedule as you
know i've just had twins so a lot of my
time during the week involves making
sure that they're hard at work editing
video
making sure that they're hard at work
having a great childhood now on top of
that last wednesday was just full of big
releases you had the rb1 finale ms
marvel episode 3 the umbrella academy on
netflix and also doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness he also wanted to
do a big easter egg video for that but
as mentioned it was a pretty busy day
then we had the boys dropping on friday
and because i get those episodes early i
tend to try and do as much work as i can
on a thursday so we can just hit the
ground running friday and then on friday
i can do a video that i release either
saturday or sunday so even when we
aren't dropping videos me and the team
are still working on others however
saying that i also dropped the umbrella
academy ending explain on thursday so we
didn't really stop posting now the way i
weighed it up was it's a completely
mess it was so busy and i just thought
look it's the obi-wan finale and the
umbrella academy also has the finale in
it as well as it was the full season
which meant i either covered those two
things last week or i wouldn't get a
chance to do them because of how much
other stuff is coming out now i figured
i could miss a week of miss marvel i
mean that's why they call it miss marvel
and then drop the most important parts
of episode 3 in this video do a stupid
joke at the start and no one would be
any wiser and it worked because this
video was so bad you're like thankful i
didn't waste my time last week watching
an episode three breakdown on top of
this crap one as well so you're bloody
welcome but not nothing against ms
marvel really enjoyed episode three it
just happened to land on a day where
there was a season finale along with an
entire season of umbrella academy so i
just didn't have the time and that's
what it boils down to there's not a big
conspiracy i just didn't have the time
to do it yeah but thanks for watching
and i'll be honest with you i did feel a
bit bad that i let people down not
posting it but if it hadn't been the
other way around with wednesday being
the ms marvel finale and it was just
episode 3 of obi-wan then then i would
have prioritized the miz marvel finale
over that it's just
we're the way things worked out and i've
got no idea why disney continue just
dropping everything on wednesday because
there's no other days in the week it all
has to be that day
anyway i hope you enjoyed the video and
uh i'd love to hear your thoughts on it
below sorry for the crap explanation as
well now as a thank you for sitting
until this part if you drop a comment
i'll let you in in on summit yeah we're
giving away three copies of everything
everywhere all at once on the 15th of
july and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now see if that's
you then message me on twitter heavy
spoilers you want some emails to watch
that make sure you check out our
breakdown of ms marvel episode 3 which
will be linked on screen right now i'm
just kidding you chump we've got the
boys and westworld get over there now
take care peace